so again my name is christoph
i work for thoughtworks i do a lot of
stuff um
also front-end stuff and um
besides from from hacking um i like
hacking i like building stuff i like
languages um but today i like to talk
about something that has been interested
me for the last year
um i call it a panoramic tour
through html5 rendering itself today and
it seems that
engineering carefully engineering the
title kind of helped because
a lot of guys here today that's good um
but what is this about today what do i
want to talk about um
so in the last in the next 30 minutes
i'd like to
misuse a few browser features some of
those new
um i and that so to make it fit in
jsconf we use a lot of javascript
um to play around with svg html css dom
and i'm not sure if you heard from that
before the css object model
i do claim that we go probably go where
no man or woman has gone before
let's see if i can hold up to this and i
hope that we have some fun on the way
because it's not as much about the yen
product it's more about the way um
how to get there because i think um i
had some fun on the way and i hope you
guys have some fun uh
going through with that um a special
welcome to the chrome devs today
um i have a few treats for you guys um
there's three bugs i'd like to fix uh in
the next few weeks maybe they're not
bugs so i have to be careful
but i already talked to mike west
yesterday and um
it seems that we can tackle a few of
those things um today i'm using firefox
because firefox is most helpful in the
stuff that we'll be doing today
but chrome does a good job too um
so specifically what we're going to do
today is
we'll be trying to uh trigger the html
rendering capabilities
that the browser exposes well it doesn't
expose it actually the browser is a huge
html renderer
but normally i'm not allowed to call it
from javascript
i'm trying to to work around the the
waze
and try to make the browser give me a
screenshot of
random web pages or random html um
we're going to render html to a canvas
it sounds a bit boring
but let's see in other words and that's
what i learned yesterday from dominic's
talk
um uh we are building a polyfill um if
you guys
uh didn't uh join this awesome talk uh
probably phil and i'm trying to explain
that in my words it might be wrong don't
make him correct me but
um if you guys know a polyfill the
polyfill tries to
make a browser follow a standard the
browser hasn't implemented that yet
you're going to write a polyfill to make
it work
a polyfill is not filling a gap that
standard created there's no standard for
this it probably will get a standard if
you guys think it's useful
so um if that makes sense um
so we're going to um add um
new capabilities to the canvas which is
basically just
draw html um that's just that tiny
method is um what we will be talking
today
um it sounds easy and it actually is um
maybe um here's a quick solution um
that is code that only works in firefox
and sadly only works in the chrome mode
of firefox uh i'm posing a bit right now
because i actually don't know what that
exactly means
i know that firefox is underneath
written in a lot of javascript
i just don't know how to uh to trigger
that code i'm because i'm not really
into that space but i know that that
works
so what we do what it does is uh it gets
a canvas
and in the end it draws a tab
the content of a tab to that canvas
um not sure whether chrome has something
like that i know that if that
safari for example and chrome do show
you screenshots i guess that must be
implemented somehow possibly in
javascript
but that's how firefox does that so that
sounds pretty easy
um but as i kind of indicated um
it does not work in the normal web page
but that's what my goal is i'd like to
call this from
any random webpage why
is it not why is it not available in the
web page well there's security concerns
and there are
have been awesome talks today yesterday
also from mark west about
why you want to limit what your websites
or your javascript is allowed to do
and if your javascript would be
allowed to render random web content
from random sources
to a canvas it would allow you to
inspect this
and do something with that so sadly
um it does there's no easy way to to
make it work
so i like to ignore any concerns
that any content security policy or same
origin
policy has and like to work around it
let's see if we can do that
so um you guys i guess are all huge fans
of svg
and svg unknown to me maybe unknown to
you has a foreign object
a tag the foreign object lets you allow
to embed
any kind of xhtml it actually allows you
without html code but you have to
convert it to html this is a valid svg
and that is basically an image that just
shows html
so maybe you see where i'm getting here
i'm
i'm allowed to draw images to to the
canvas now i have an image basically
which includes html so let's see if we
can build on that
so um one short step as i said xhtml
um i can't for random html added i must
convert it i need to provide
html and firefox
by looking at the chrome developers
makes it very easy here um
there is an xml serializer or you just
ignore the the basic code just the xml
serializer
that helps you to convert any random
document into
xhtml now in chrome and safari that does
not work
and the guys have a point they say the
standard does not require xml serializer
to
transform an html document into xhtml
so they have a different behavior there
it's actually firefox that's doing
something that that
understand it doesn't uh ask for so
let's assume we have a way of converting
that if we if we're going to implement
that
from today in chrome and safari we need
to have our own substitution for that
and i'm
i'm really looking into a lot of html
parsers right lately
um i've been looking for forgot one um
for for a year um i might have found
something this afternoon but
um there's no good uh there's no good
html to
html converter out there in pure
javascript that works in the browser
so if you guys know of something like
that just come up to me please
so considering that we have that um what
can we do with that right now
so in the future um with blobs
we can basically just throw our svg into
a blob
and create an object url from that this
object url
is something we can just pipe into an
image and that image could go into the
canvas and we're done
it's not that easy because safari isn't
that far at least it
hasn't been that far a month ago or
something
so we need to fall back to data uries uh
your eyes i guess you know that um
these i think were kind of designed for
adding small image content
um to make your life easier to to maybe
um improve the bandwidth problems
uh and improve upon problems and
what we can do is basically if you have
an svg that's where we started
we can create an image with that basic
scheme here just add a data image with
the type svgxml
charts that you have eight and then
throw the svg inside
so what does that mean um we can now
bring this together
and remember what our task was our task
was render html
into the canvas so what we can do is
create a new image
throw in the svg content and then get
the canvas and draw the image
and that is pretty easy pretty simple
code
and i like to say congratulations um
it looks like we're done what we did is
emulated html
beforehand converting that to html using
foreign object into an svg
then we converted that into a data uri
got an image and used the
context draw image and that's good
so yeah not right we have a few minutes
left right so
there's more things to cover svg
is not allowed to um include any
external resources
um so i didn't know that beforehand but
if you
in going to include svg in your web
pages your svgs
are not allowed to link to external
resources that again is
as far as i understand for security
reasons so
that is bad though because our problem
is um
html we want to render html and html
allows for a lot of
external resources and i'm not sure i
think i covered all of them
you have images you have i'm not sure if
you knew about input
elements of type image you have style
sheets
you have inside style sheets background
images you have
style.css may import other css
stylesheets
you have fonts and all those things
um linked to excellent resources and all
those i'd like to render to
the canvas too so here's a
kind of nifty idea we could try to embed
those resources into the svg
svg could take data your eyes inside too
right
so um how do we find those external
elements
my goal still is find a generic way of
piping html into the canvas so let's
find an automated solution to
to get that done so that looks like
pretty
simple code i think you create an empty
document um you pipe your html into that
document
and then you just get elements by tag
name or i don't even need to query all i
can do is just get all the images out
and i can just iterate over those images
and
do something with that right now i know
i now have all my images
that my html references what do i need
to do
um that's how my image looks like um
it's an external image
and i'd like to embed that well we
talked about data uris before
so what i can do is just basically get
that image
image get the content and stuff it into
um as a data uri into the source and i'm
done
and how can we do that we just use our
plain simple ajax
i load the content via ajax um and
that's how i construct it i add that
data uri i'll
encode that to base 64 via b2a function
and i might be done um
well first things first ajax you know
needs to follow same origin policy so
this will not allow me to load random
web pages it only allows to me to load
stuff that i'm allowed to see
so just need to to mention that
secondly loading
binary images through ajax it's crazy
that's not what ajax was designed to be
ajax was designed well the name says xml
right
it's used for xml and and uh json you're
allowed to load
um text not binary data
so uh xhr 2 xml http request 2
um now has um capabilities for loading
binary data which
gives you back a blob again safari is
not playing along well here
so what we're doing um we need to
find a workaround and um that's what
i've been doing the whole time i've just
been throwing things into google
and quite often land on stack overflow
and find a solution for my problem i had
so
that's something you can find on a stack
overflow with a big sign saying don't do
that
um that's ugly it's bad but it seems to
work in all those browsers so
you know screw screw uh xhml uh
http request two and screw blobs i can
do that with our browsers and i'm
happy um it's pretty slow though if you
load like megabytes of data and you
iterate through all the
the code points so what it actually does
the code um i mean you can
um you can read but it basically just um
converts it um from a to code point and
throws away all the um other um bits and
just converts it back
um ugly but it works so um we're good
um second second point now we i kind of
describe how to inline images
what about background images it seems a
bit similar they are images too
but the problem here is background
images are
referenced in css how do i find my
background images i need to dig
into css now that basically requires me
parsing css
to to find which uh which resources i
need to inline
so we need to build something like this
function past css
and if i throw in a span that has a
background image i need to find this
external image png
so let's write a css parser
you see we're getting at it's getting a
bit complicated to be fair though
we're done pretty quickly that is the
slide that describes the css parser
um well we can just use the css parser
from the browser i didn't know that i've
been using um
a pure javascript solution for a long
time until i realized that the css
existed it's the css object model the
browser allows
you to basically access its parser
so that's the nifty code that just does
it what it does is
you create a style element you pipe your
css
content to that style element and then
you need to
do one very important step the browser
only starts to evaluate
that css if it actually needs to do so
so you need to create a fake
document add that style element to that
document
and then the browser starts to to pass
that css
and then you're done the style
element.sheet.css rules
lists you gives you a list or kind of
list list like
element to access all your css rules um
that is and when i found this piece of
code i thought that's so awesome i
didn't know that existed
this is uh basically the browser doing
css parsing
um to be fair it's really an ugly api to
be fair if i just um
if i envision how i would do that in in
node.js or any other programming
language i would require the css parser
and tell the css parser to evaluate my
code
it turns out that in general in in the
browser dom you always tend to kind of
access some weird api
to get some some stuff done to be fair i
think nobody actually
uh designed um actually designed that
for that use case i don't think anybody
wanted the user or the
javascript to pass css well i need that
so here i am
i want to get that stuff done so can we
put this together
um we now can pass our rules
we get a list so we get a list of rules
and then we can iterate over those rules
just like we did with the images before
we go through all the rules check if it
has a background image
and if it does call our
virtual method do inline image url so
this method is something we already did
for the image we can do the same stuff
with the background images and we're
done
so i showed you how to inline images now
we're doing the same stuff with
background images only we need to pass
css before and
we're good so um
next step number three um
what about uh link elements to inline um
to the reference style sheets um the my
html is allowed to
reference other style sheets if i want
to render my html i want to
want to make sure that my style sheets
are rendered alongside
so i need to embed them too remember we
are rendering svg to a canvas
and the svg is embedding html but it's
not allowed to reference any external
stuff i'm inlining everything
so um it looks simple at first
um we just kind of go with similar path
as with the image we're using ajax to
load the content
it's simple here because we're actually
using a reloading text
what we do is we throw out the link and
in the same place we put a style element
that includes the content of
of that css make sure that you put the
style at and the same position as a link
because css
um as we learned today again follows the
order of
the declarations so be careful here
we're not done yet um it looks simple to
just embed that content but
the resources inside the css i'm just
inlining
all those relative links are relative to
um
the source through the url of the
stylesheet
so i can i can't just pull in um the css
and just dump it into html
all those links will be broken all the
relative links will be broken
what i need to do is carefully inspect
my um my css unloading so
i need to pass this stuff again i need
to find all those
references background images fonts
import rules
and i need to adapt all those um urls
to a relative to the url of the stash of
the mother starship basically
so for example if i have if i have an
image
dot dot slash images dot sprite png
inside asset style default css
i need to replace a dot dot with the
assets from the start sheet
so um i'm using um a pure js
ul parser uri dot js which allows me
to base my url absolutely i think it's
the wrong name it should be relatively
to the sheet url
so um if i inline my css content i need
to fix all those paths
and when i fix all those paths and i'm
done then i need to go through and
replace all the background images
like just what we did before
so um there you go um
we rendered html through the cs svgs
foreign object
we inlined um not all of the external
resources by now there's a bit more as i
showed before
but we're loading binary content through
ajax all the text content through ajax
we're inventing image images
um through data uris we're embedding
style sheets
we're parsing css to find resources to
fix the paths
so what does that what does it look like
it's demo time um
i'm showing you a kind of boring demo
right now let's see if that makes sense
i have a canvas up there maybe i should
zoom in a bit
um oopsie that's a bit cut off
um
all we can do is just switch over here
that help yeah and
so um yeah back again so what i have
there's a
text area um where i can
type in arbitrary html and this is um
drawn into the canvas up there if you
don't believe me that this is a canvas i
can show you pretty easily
if i right click on this in in firefox
it allows me to view the image
so what i have right now here is my html
as an image
and if you look at the uh i'm not sure
whether you can see that it's pretty
small
but you see the data ui in the browser
resource so i basically now have an
image
that i just rendered inside the browser
with an external image and i can do way
more crazy stuff with that
back to demo so um
we could say we're done here um i'd like
to give you
a small bonus let's see if that makes
fun
um i don't only want to render a static
html
i want to um render
an html page that includes javascript
um i want to make sure that if my
javascript does some stuff with my
page that i render the final outcome
so is that possible uh and it turns out
it is um
well um what i can basically do is just
um create an iframe
throw my html into that iframe and just
wait for the iframe to trigger the
unload event when the unload event
triggers
my page has done its rendering stuff
and the state kind of the state possibly
changed
and i can just then take the document of
the iframe
and then um get the html out again and
then i'll have like a different html
string
and that basically allows me to um
execute javascript at the same time
um i'm not really sure about the
sandboxing
uh stuff i did read a bit uh up on
sandboxing the iframe and it turns out
i my feeling from that was i don't need
to sandbox it it works but if you guys
have security concerns
do come up there to me and tell me if i
need to make that secure
so i'm outsourcing my security concerns
so there are a few issues here um
as i said before the same origin policy
does not allow you to to load random
content
so ajax you know that stuff what you can
do is if you
if you have control over the origins you
can expose a
common object resource of sharing is
that correct yeah
of course um a problem i had
with the webkit family i'm not sure if
i'm still allowed to call it webkit
family um
but chrome sadly cannot
write background images back so the css
parsing
that i showed earlier does not work in
chrome because of this simple bug
so what i do right now is we can just
fall back to the css
object model implementation that a guy
on github does so he's got an awesome
uh implementation for node.js which i'm
just using in the browser and that's
awesome so
um i know chrome has that stuff in that
case i'm using a polyfill
i guess so um a kind of
a special problem is if you're embedding
svgs if
if you have an svg inside your html
remember that the html goes into another
svg so you have an svg
inside your svg um that doesn't seem to
work
neither in safari nor chrome there's a
work around but
that's a basic issue
the last point is my major pain point
and that's where i needed to ask the
google guys i had a conversation with
mike yesterday maybe you listened to his
talk yesterday
as neither safari or chrome allow me to
read from the canvas
after i draw this svg to it there seems
to be
a different interpretation of what the
standard requires firefox allows you to
do that
chrome safari don't um if you want to
then work with the content
um you right now you cannot you can't
which is i think a sad state because
obviously i can't think of an attack
vector because if i'm allowed to load
all that content and i'm allowed to
render that content i should be able to
read from this um one last sad point is
ie 11 even the ie 11 preview has no
support for foreign object
so ie 11 sadly none of the ie versions
do support that stuff that we're doing
here
um good news though the stability in the
browsers have increased and
especially the firefox guys there's one
guy in firefox that seems to be
interested in that and
every time i complained um he quickly
fixed that bug
um the last book i reported was my fault
so he was nice
too so uh what's that story all about um
i ended up
putting that into a library it's on
github um
it seems a few people are using that at
least they're hitting the start button
on github i just don't know what they're
doing with that i don't have
really i don't know what people want to
use it for um
i just talked to dominic and he said
he's got an interesting uh case but i
still need to ask him
i have a i have a use case for that um
and that maybe sounds a bit weird
my original idea was i want to start
testing my css
and my idea was if i can just take
screenshots i might just compare my
screenshots
um old versus new and
my even crazy idea was i wanted to do
that in the browser
and i can now do that um i can now
render
web pages in the browser and i can do my
testing on that
that's also in github if in case you're
interested so
uh thanks a lot for listening and do
something cool with that and
i might say that because thoughtworks is
paying for for me being here uh we're
hiring if you're interested
check that out
you